let's say that I have a ramp made of ice
sake maybe a wedge or some type of an
inclined plane made of ice and make
everything of ice in this video so we
have negligible friction so this right
here is my ramp it's made of ice and
this angle right over here let's just go
with 30 degrees and let's say on this
ramp made of ice I have another block of
ice so this is a block of ice it is a
block of ice it's shiny like ice is
shiny and it has a mass it has a mass of
10 kilograms and what I want to do is
think about what's going to happen to
this block of ice so first of all what
are the forces that we know are acting
on it well we're for you if we are
assuming we're on earth and we will and
we're near the surface then there is the
force of gravity there's the force of
gravity acting on this block of ice and
the force of gravity the force of
gravity is going to be equal to its
going to or at least its magnitude it's
going to be in the downward direction
and it's magnitude is going to be the
mass of the block of ice times the
gravitational field times 9.8 meters per
second squared
so it's going to be 98 Newtons downward
so this is 98 Newtons downward I just
took 10 kilograms let me write it out so
the force due to gravity is going to be
equal to 10 kilograms times 9.8 meters
per second squared downward downward
this 9.8 meters per second squared
downward that is the that is the field
vector for the gravitational field near
the surface of the earth I guess is one
way to think about it sometimes you'll
see that a negative 9.8 meters per
second squared and then that negative is
giving you the direction implicitly
because we the convention is normally
that positive is upward negative is
downward but we'll just go with this
right over here so the magnitude of this
vector is 10 times 9.8 which is 98
kilogram meters per second squared which
the same thing as Newtons so the
magnitude here is 98 Newtons and it is
pointing downwards now what we want to
do is break this vector up into the
components that are perpendicular and
parallel to the surface of
this ramp so let's do that so first
let's think about perpendicular to the
surface of the ramp so perpendicular to
the surface of the ramp so this right
over here is a right angle and we saw on
the last video that whatever angle this
is over here is that is also going to be
this angle over here so this angle over
here is also going to be a 30-degree
angle and we can use that information to
figure out the magnitude of this orange
vector right over here and remember this
orange vector is the is the component of
the force of gravity do that is
perpendicular to the plane and then
there's going to be some component that
is parallel to the plane I'll draw that
in yellow some component of the force of
gravity that is parallel to the plane
and clearly this is a right angle
because this is perpendicular to the
plane and this is parallel to the plane
so they're going to in this
perpendicular plane it's also
perpendicular to this vector right over
here so we can use some basic
trigonometry like we did in the last
video to figure out the magnitude of
this orange and this yellow vector right
over here this orange vector is
magnitude over the hypotenuse is going
to be equal to the cosine of 30 or you
could say that the magnitude of this is
9898 times the cosine of 30 times the
cosine of 30 degrees Newtons 98 times
the cosine of 30 degrees Newtons and if
you want the whole vector it's in this
direction in the direction going into
into the surface of the plane and based
on the simple trigonometry and we go
into this into a little bit more detail
in the last video we know that the
component of this vector that is
parallel to the surface of this plane is
going to be ninety eight ninety eight
sine of thirty degrees sine of thirty
degrees sine of thirty degrees and this
comes straight out of this magnitude
which is the OP which is opposite to the
angle over the hypotenuse opposite over
hypotenuse is equal to sine of an angle
and we did all the work over you don't
want to keep repeating it but I always
want to emphasize that this is coming
straight out of basic trigonometry
straight out of basic trigonometry
so once you do that we know the
different components we can calculate
them cosine of 30 degrees is square root
of 3 over 2 sine of 30 degrees is 1/2
that's just one of those things that you
learn and you can derive it yourself
using 30-60-90 triangles or actually
even equilateral triangles or you could
use a calculator but it's also one of
those things that you memorize when you
take trigonometry so no no kind of
magical trick I did here and so if you
evaluate this 98 times the square root
of 3 over 2 Newton's tells us that let
me write it in that same orange color
the force the component of gravity that
is perpendicular to the plane and this
kind of implicitly gives us this
direction it's perpendicular to the
plane but the force component of gravity
this perpendicular plane is equal to 98
times square root of 3 over 2 98 divided
by 2 is 49 so it's equal to 49 times the
square root of 3 Newtons and it's
Direction is into the surface of the
plane or downward or let me just write
into into surface of plane surface of
the plane or the surface of the ramp and
it's in this direction over here and I
have to do this because it's a vector I
have to tell you what direction it's
going in and the component of the force
of gravity that is parallel the
component of the force of gravity that's
parallel I drew it down here but I can
just shift it up over here same exact
vector the component of gravity that is
parallel to the surface of the plane is
98 times sine of 30 that's 98 times
one-half which is 49 Newtons and it's
going in that direction or parallel to
the surface of the plane parallel I
always have trouble spelling parallel
parallel to don't even know if I spelled
it right surface of the plane so what's
going to happen here well if these were
the only forces acting on it so if we
had a net force going into the surface
of the plane of 49 square roots of 3
Newtons if this was the only force
acting in this dimension or in the
dimension that is perpendicular to the
surface of the plane what would happen
well then the block would just
accelerate at least just due to this
force it would accelerate downward it
would accelerate into the surface of the
plane but we know it's not going to
accelerate we know that there's this big
wedge of ice here that is keeping it
from accelerating in that direction so
the it's at least in this dimension
there will be no acceleration when I
talk about this dimension I'm talking
about I'm talking about in the direction
that is perpendicular to the surface of
the plane
there will be no acceleration because
this wedge is here so the wedge is
exerting a force that completely
counteracts the force the the
perpendicular component of gravity in
that force you might guess what it's
called so this the wedge is exerting a
force just like that that's going to be
98 Newtons upward so I will call it the
wedge is going to be exerting a force
that is 98 oh sorry not 98 49 square
roots of 3 because this right here is 49
square roots of 3 Newtons into and so
this is 49 square roots of 3 Newtons out
of out of the surface out of the surface
and this is the normal force it is the
force perpendicular to the surface that
is essentially you can kind of view is
it's the contact force that the perp
that the that the in this case that the
surface is exerting to keep this block
of ice from accelerating in that
direction we're not talking about
accelerating straight towards the center
there's we're talking about accelerating
in that direction we broke up the force
into into kind of this the perpendicular
direction and the parallel direction so
you have this counteracting normal force
and that's why that's why you don't have
that's why you don't have the but the
block plummeting or accelerating into
the plane now what other forces do we
have well we have the force that's
parallel parallel to the surface and if
we assume that there's no friction and I
can assume that there's no friction in
this in this video because we are
assuming that it is ice on ice what is
going to happen there is no
counteracting force to this 49 Newtons
49 Newtons parallel downwards I should
say parallel downwards to the surface of
the plane so what
going to happen well it's going to
accelerate in that direction you have
force is equal to mass times
acceleration force is equal to mass
times acceleration or you divide both
sides by mass you get force over mass is
equal to acceleration over here our
force is 49 Newtons in that direction in
that direction parallel downwards to the
surface of the plane and so if you
divide both by mass if you divide both
of these if you divide it by mass so
that's the same thing as dividing it by
10 kilograms dividing by 10 kilograms
that will give you acceleration that
will give you that will give you our
acceleration so acceleration is 49
Newton's divided by 10 kilograms in that
direction in the in this in this this
direction right over there and 49
divided by 10 is 4.9 and the Newton's
divided by kilograms is meters per
second squared so then you get your
acceleration your acceleration is going
to be 4.9 m/s squared
and maybe I could say parallel parallel
that's what that's two bars or maybe
I'll write parallel parallel downwards
downwards to surface to the surface now
I'm going to leave you there and I'll
let you think about another thing that
I'll address in the next video is what
if you had this just standing still if
it wasn't accelerating downwards if it
wasn't accelerating and sliding down
what would what would be the force
that's keeping it in a kind of a static
State we'll think about that in the next
video